now this morning a teenager is fighting
for his life in hospital after being
stabbed in the chest on a bus in North
London yesterday afternoon just the
latest victim in what some are
describing as a national emergency so is
enough being done to tackle knife crime
well joining us now is the health
secretary thank you very much for being
with us on the program this morning
you've written in The Sunday Telegraph
today about the role the NHS can play in
trying to help tackle knife crime so
what are you proposing well I think all
of us touched and moved by these awful
stories of these these attacks these
murders due to knife crime and I think
lots of us look at the children who are
involved and the young adults and think
they could be our children and this is
one of the reasons why it's really hit a
nerve with so many people
the truth is with knife crime you can
only tackle it with lots of different
people come together it isn't just an
issue for the police although that
obviously they're very important and so
I want the NHS to play its full part in
making sure that we rise to this
challenge that everybody feels is so
important to tackle and not least
because when these young people when
these children arrive in hospital that
is a moment when you can intervene and
try to tackle the problem and you know
they were just little kids just a few
years ago and the idea that this can
only be tackled with the strong arm of
the law is is wrong when they arrived in
hospital that's a moment that you can
really make a strong intervention and
get people involved to try to turn
people's lives around at the same time
now NHS staff are already under immense
time pressure we know about the
challenges in the NHS as well document
it I mean is this really just trying to
put a sticking-plaster if you like over
the fact that so many police have been
cut around 20,000 since 2010 and trying
to get NHS workers to plug that gap no
it's about working across the
different silos of government if you
like this approach has been tried in
Baltimore which has in the past been one
of the most violent cities in the world
and and it's worked very effectively to
reduce by around 85% the number of
people who come back with another knife
injury and it's about getting the right
intervention to these to these children
to these young people at the right
moment and often the moment that you
arrive in hospital is a it is obviously
a critical moment for anybody and that's
when people are open to changing their
behavior and to responding differently
and if you just treat the physical
person then you're only treating part of
the problem because what we don't want
to do is just patch people up and send
them back out into exactly the same
environment that led them in in the
first place
what we want to do is at that moment
intervene to give them the full support
to turn around to get out of the gangs
and to and to make the changes needed to
get away from knife crime okay now we do
of course need to talk about brexit the
voter's looming next week already it
feels as if the mood music it's pretty
bleak around Westminster so is it
inevitable that the Prime Minister is
going to lose the vote on Tuesday no
it's not inevitable it's in the gift of
MPs to get on and deliver on brexit and
I very much hope that's what people will
vote for because that is what the public
voted for almost three years ago now we
have the opportunity on Tuesday to be
able to deliver on the referendum I'll
be voting to deliver on the results of
the referendum and I very much hope that
all of my colleagues will too and at the
same time they of course that people are
looking to what will happen if that vote
doesn't go through Theresa May has
promised MPs will get to decide whether
or not that would mean leaving with no
deal on the 29th of March or extending
article 50 so can you just confirm if
those votes are deaf
gonna happen this week and if they are
how you would vote on the No Deal
decision
well the Prime Minister has said said
that absolutely but I think the truth is
that in the event of this vote on
Tuesday not going through there would
nobody knows what would happen in in the
in everything that followed there would
be total uncertainty that would be the
only certainty and so I would appeal
very directly to all of my colleagues
from right across the party and
supporters in other parties people who
believe that brexit should happen
believe we should honor the result of
the referendum I would appeal to every
single one of them to vote for this deal
whether or not they they like any of the
individual details Benjamin Franklin
said of the US Constitution I vote for
this with all its faults and I think
that's the approach that we need to take
on Tuesday is to get together and vote
to deliver on the result and then we
won't have to have any votes afterwards
on on what happens next we can get on
because there's so many opportunities in
the future there's so many opportunities
that we can seize if we can deliver on
the brexit result and and then help
shape Britain in the 21st century in
what we can achieve post brexit instead
of constantly having this fog of brexit
descended over our politics as it has
been over the last few months so hang on
it just to be really clear are you
saying then that there is no guarantee
that if the government loses the vote on
Tuesday that MPs will then get to decide
whether or not to leave with no deal or
to extend article 50 no I'm not saying
that at all that's what the Prime
Minister has committed to I was making
the much broader point that we wouldn't
know what would happen in those votes we
wouldn't know what the EU would then
come back with in many ways that you
believes that it would be in the driving
seat in that if this vote doesn't go
through which is not where anybody wants
to
certainly not where I want to be the
point I was making was not about the
individual votes on Wednesday or
Thursday the point is about the the
broader politics of uncertainty that
we'd have if this vote doesn't go
through and that's why I'm going to vote
for it and it's why I think I just I
appeal directly to all of my colleagues
to vote for it whatever the whatever the
details because it's so important that
we deliver on the result of the
referendum and it's so important that we
can then get on to all the amazing
things this country can do and all the
other things that we want to be talking
about ok well that's certainly coming
through loud and clear that you're gonna
be voting in support with the prime
minister's deal would you what would you
vote for though because I know that you
want to focus of course on the vote on
Tuesday but I think it's not an
unreasonable question to ask after last
time the prime minister suffered the
biggest defeat of any sitting government
when she put the deal to the house would
you vote to leave with no deal or to
extend article 15 well I don't want
those votes to happen and I'm not going
to talk about how I'm going to vote in
them ahead of time these negotiations
are still ongoing
you know there's still been this weekend
have been negotiations going on in
Brussels to try to get more out of the
EU that to provide assurances in order
to get everybody behind winning that
vote on Tuesday so I I think that's
absolutely as you say what we need to
concentrate on what happens after that
if the vote goes the wrong way is is
clearly a huge uncertainty but I'm not
going to go into how I'm going to vote
on any of those on only have votes until
until those votes are called and I very
much hope that they won't be and there's
a way that we can all avoid having those
votes called and that's motive of the
deal on Tuesday you're talking there
about the uncertainty that would happen
if the deal doesn't go through of course
the NHS is one of the institutions that
would be very very impacted by whatever
happens when it comes to a brexit so
would there be more money for the NHS if
the Prime Minister still go through
well yes the 20 billion pounds extra
that we're putting into the NHS is
happening in any brexit scenario that's
committed by the whole government that's
very important and and you know talking
about how we spend that money and what
we want from the NHS in the future
building on the long term plan that we
published earlier this year these are
the sorts of things that I think we
should be talking about they're the
sorts of things that we need to be
working on to deliver for the people who
we serve delivering on the referendum
result is a first step towards getting
back to talking about the
bread-and-butter issues that people
really care about on the doorstep so the
the you know the the details of that
plan what we need to do to make sure
that people take more responsibility for
their own health as well the the the
prevention agenda and of course dealing
with issues like knife crime that we
were talking about at the start these
are all the sorts of things that I want
our politics to get back to talking
about because they are the things that
really matter for improving this country
and delivering on delivering on brexit
and doing it you know taking the deal
that's on the table and delivering on
that is a it's a critical first step to
be able to making that progress the
world college of radiologists warren
recently that hospitals will have no
choice but to prioritize which patients
receive cancer treatment if there's no
deal so is that a description that you
recognize will there some people maybe
have delays their cancer treatment if
there's no deal no I heard those remarks
and they're wrong we have plans in place
to ensure that we can get all of the
drugs into the country in in in in
whatever the brexit scenario that
includes the very short shelf-life
isotopes that are needed for for
treating cancer and so there are there
are plans in place to make sure that all
of that can happen we've been working
very hard on making sure that the NHS is
there in also
Constance's in whatever the brexit vote
and of course you know in a way the NHS
is designed for dealing with problems
with with you know with individual
crises in individual people's lives and
more broadly we prepare for all sorts of
eventualities in the NHS and I would say
that the NHS has really risen to the
challenge of the concerns about No Deal
brexit in the event that the were very
serious blockages at the border you know
there's 12,300 medicines that we use in
England at any one time and we've now
got a plan for how those medicines can
come through even if there's blockages
at the border so this is something we've
been doing a lot of work on to make sure
and that it can happen and now we're
confident that if everybody does what
they need to do then that supply of
medicines will continue unhindered now
just finally before you go when I was
researching this interview I couldn't
help but notice how unbelievably
competitive you seem to be so in 2005
you got frostbite after trying to play
the most northerly game of cricket ever
in the Arctic in 2012 you trained as a
jockey and then actually won a race that
Newmarket
you entered Parma in 2010 now your house
secretary so are you so competitive but
now you've got your eye on the top job
could you be persuaded no I could see
where this question was going right from
the start no I think that I think that
politics and in particular in government
it's a real it's a team effort
I love being health secretary I feel
like I can make a contribution and I
think that it's really important that we
work together I mean this is one of the
reasons why I feel on brexit that we
need to come together for this vote on
Tuesday but more broadly I see it a
great privilege to serve in government
and in the cabinet and I think of the
you know the millions of people who rely
on the services that I'm responsible for
every day and I think it's a good team
effort you know people ask me why
you doubt - it's a it's a team effort
and I thoroughly enjoyed being part of
that team